[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to the Googleplex.
This is an incredible place
with lots of great stuff being
worked on every single day.
Before I worked here,
I always wondered
what it be like to
come to the Googleplex,
meet up with a Googler,
and have coffee with them,
and just chat about what
they do, how they do it
and why they do it.
And today, we're going
to do exactly that.
So welcome to this episode
of "Coffee With A Googler."
Today, I'm meeting
with Francesc Campoy.
He's a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud platform,
and he specializes in
the language called Go.
So welcome, Francesc.
Thanks for joining us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh,
thank you for having me.
I'm very happy.
It's an honor to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Oh,
thank you so much.
So, Go.
What's so special about Go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So Go
is a primary language
that was created five
years ago here at Google.
It was created
with the main goal
of solving Google problems.
The most important
thing when you--
the most important word that
comes to mind when you think
about Google is, of course--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Scale, right, yes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Scale.
There you go.
So, it's basically scale
in three different axes
of the same problem
that we have.
One of them is how many
engineers or developers
do you have per project?
And Google is pretty well
known to have really--
a really big number
of engineers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
If those engineers
are using a primary
language that
doesn't help them interact
with each other, share a code,
be able to read and understand
what the other wrote,
that's a big problem.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I see.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
Go concentrates a lot
on keeping it really simple,
having very good readability.
So even if you might not have
read a single line of Go code
ever in your life, you
might find a Go program
and find it surprisingly
familiar, actually.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So it's
not like C++ in that regard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Uhh,
not exactly, yes.
That's actually-- C++ is the
language that we still use
mostly for servers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So Go was
supposed to replace C++.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Ah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That
didn't really happen yet.
It actually surprisingly
came-- most people coming to Go
are coming from other
languages like Python and Ruby,
because they like the
simplicity of the language.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The second
axis of scale for these problems
is the number of cores we
have in a single machine.
Nowadays, for instance, you
can check on the Google cloud
platform.
We provide instances
that have 32 cores.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If
you have 32 cores
and you are not able
to use them correctly
because your primary language
doesn't support concurrency
or a parallelism, you're
wasting money, basically.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
it's really important.
Concurrency is a
fundamental part of Go.
And finally, the number
of machines we're running.
Everything now is
about the cloud.
The cloud is about running
across a big fleet of machines.
You need to be able to
communicate correctly
between different machines.
But these, we have been doing it
at Google for ages, basically.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah, yeah.
It's in your DNA, right?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So Go was created from
the beginning keeping
all of those aspects in mind.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Now, Go recently had a new
release dropped, right?
Was it 1.4?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it was 1.4, yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
What's in this?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So in Go 1.4, there
was not much new from
the point of view
of features of the language.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It was
more about improving things.
One of the things
that we improved
was having a better
garbage collector.
We keep on doing that
every single time.
That's one of the
topics of research
that we're actually working
on very, very closely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Then
some small features.
One of the small features
that was not really important
at that point but will become
way more important on 1.5
is the support for Android.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Android.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
We gave some basic support
for Android, and with Go 1.5,
the support for Android
will be much more important.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
what kind of Android apps
can you build with Go right now?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
The idea is that we
don't want to replace Java.
Java is the language of Android,
and we're totally OK with that.
What we're trying to do is
replace all the languages
that people have been
using to, for instance,
write games, where basically,
you're not depending
that much on the UI of Android.
You're basically writing
everything from scratch.
Your buttons don't need to
look like Android buttons,
for instance.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: In those
cases, basically what you
need is to be able to open and
close connections and files
and then basically write into
the screen and play some music.
All of those are
actually powered,
not of the SDK of
Android, but the NDK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Got it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
what we're supporting.
With Go 1.5, we will
give support for Android,
the NDK only.
And the good thing about
this is that what we're doing
is we created this
Go mobile thing.
Go Mobile is just a layer of
abstraction between your Go
program and the Android behind.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Now, the cool thing
is that that Go Mobile
layer abstraction
has been designed with
multiple platforms in mind.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So we're
also working on iOS.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And very soon we
expect to be able to say, you
can write your app just in Go
and deploy it at the same
time, both on the Apple Store
and on the Play Store by Google.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, nice.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty
excited about that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah.
Now, you said that a lot
of that's coming in 1.5.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yes, that's-- by now,
we're able to run
things on Android.
That has been,
actually, the case
for a little bit, because Go is
compiled in a lot of platforms.
ARM is one of those, so you
would be able to run it.
But the possibility of
contacting-- of using the NDK
and being able to use OpenGL
and these kinds of things
on Android, that will
come with Go 1.5.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
So it runs on Android,
and you mentioned earlier
on that runs in the cloud.
But the cloud is so diverse.
There must be lots
of great scenarios,
like, where else is Go
making good stuff happen?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so there's actually
so many new projects
that are using Go.
One of the ones that everybody's
talking about is Docker.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Everybody knows--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So Docker uses Go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
Nobody knows that
Docker's bringing Go--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I didn't know that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --but it is.
Yeah, it is bringing Go.
There's also all the
things that Cooper Net is--
Cooper Net is also bringing Go,
so Cooper Net is just basically
like the open-sourced
version of how
Google manages data centers.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There's
so many other more.
Corel has, for instance,
new Linux distribution.
They also use Go.
And I think that the
main reason for this
is that because on the
cloud, you need two things.
One is you need to use
very well your machines,
so concurrency is important.
And then again, you need to
use the network very well.
So the networking package
that we have on Google
works really well.
So it's a little bit of both.
Then the last thing that
I think is very important
is that we provide
multi-platform compilation
and also cross-platform,
which means
that I can compile an
exit binary for Windows
from my Linux machine.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Basically it allows it to
work in whatever environment
you want, and then deploy it
to the cloud, whatever cloud is
using, which is a great thing.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
that's pretty cool.
So if a developer wants
to get started with this,
there's so much
diversity there, right?
So if a developer wants to start
programming in Go so that they
can reach that
diversity, how would you
recommend they get started?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Well, I think
that the most important web
page to remember is golang.org,
which is the Go home page.
Then from there,
you're going to find
a variety of resources,
documentation, tutorials
and so on.
And there is a specific tutorial
that is really important.
It's very successful.
It's Go tour.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Go tour.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: The Go tour.
So that's in tour.golang.org.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Tour.golang.org, OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, I'll
have to remember that one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That allows you to
learn Go without having
to install anything.
So basically, you
get to a web page
and you're going to be able
to see some instruction
on the side, some Go
code on the other side
that you can edit and run and
just play with the language
and understand the basics
without having to install
anything on your computer.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty cool.
Great way to learn.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I think that's the best
way to learn without having
to engage into anything.
Just go there, try it.
If you like it, that's awesome.
If you don't like it,
well, let us know.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, showing
how we can improve it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
thank you so much, Francesc.
And thank you for watching
this episode of "Coffee
With A Googler."
I've learned so much about
Go, and I hope you have, too.
So if you want to learn more
about Google and about Go,
subscribe to the Google
Developers YouTube channel
where we've got lots
of great videos.
And if you've any
questions for me
or any questions
for Francesc, just
please leave them in
the comments below.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]